So let me just tell you what the schedule is then so tonight
we have two main sessions session one
is about to happen. Then
we're going to take a break and then we'll be session two and then
tomorrow will be session three and
then after session three we will have some breakout.
So let me just tell you what the topics of
each session is tonight's first
session is called why do we marry?
Followed by what happened to us? And then
tomorrow the good one is how do
we reconnect? So that's kind of
the plan for the weekend.
Yeah, and as me and my colleagues have been talking. I'm by
the way, I'm Mason Phillips. I'm the counseling
director over at ministries of Jesus. If you have no idea who I am.
You probably don't but we've been talking a lot about what
marriage is need right now. And what we've noticed
is that people want to be together and when the
going gets rough, they just don't really know how to
make that stay together. So make sense.
I'm sure we'll learn that it makes
sense as we go on this weekend. So my
name is Jimmy Quinn and I work here at Henderson
Hills and I work with our marriage Ministry. And
so that's why I'm here. But as Mason
and I have been thinking about this weekend.
From a church point of view some of
the things that I've seen maybe you guys are like me.
When I was in college, it seemed like
everyone around me was like getting a girlfriend and then
like getting engaged and then they get married like
man. Everyone around me is getting married. And then
of course I get married and then everyone
around me a couple years later like there's something
in the water like there's pregnancies everywhere babies everywhere
and then I have a baby and now I have two kids girls
and you know just seems like that's what it is.
Well now I'm in this stage of life where
it's like man my friends are having
some marriage problems and it just seems like everywhere. I
turn there's like not just a little
bit of rocks and
bumpy roads, but like Boulders and
so I just have a heart for that and and I
just want like marriages to like sustain and and
to to stay together because I
think in scripture we see that the marriage
relationship is depiction of our relationship
with our Lord. So
Marriages need help and most of
all as we'll talk about this weekend is they need Jesus and
maybe even a good therapist would help
as well and we have one here tonight. His name
is Larry Roberts. He's a good friend of mine. I've known
him a long time. He also has been a great mentor to
me in my life. As I was becoming a therapist. I learned
a whole lot from him whether that's good or bad. He'll tell you and so
You know, he loves Jesus. He loves
to see marriages come together and follow
Christ and so before
He comes up here though. He's going to talk a
lot about a lot of different topics. And we want to
make sure that he answers all your questions. But in case he doesn't we want
you to have a way to ask some of those questions. So we've got a
QR code on screen. If you were to pull your phone out right this second
and hover your camera over that like you do on
the menu during the pandemic at the restaurant. You know,
that can't same kind of deal. You should be able to pull up a form.
It's very simple form and
you can just submit your questions there and we'll be looking at those throughout the
conference synthesizing them together seeing any commonalities
and hopefully we'll answer some
of those questions throughout the course of the weekend, so
And this code by the way when it
goes away, we've got them on tables out in the lobbies and things
like that. So Jimmy, do you want to pray for
us? Yeah before I pray for us. There was another
thing that I wanted to mention, you know, when you go and get
an oil change for your car most of the time
you don't see like
that it actually did anything, you know, it's like
oil you you don't really tell that it actually
worked but you know, you're supposed to get an oil change because if you don't
You know damage might happen to your vehicle. And so
tonight your marriage might be awesome and
you might be like, hey, I'm just gonna go to
Please my husband please my wife but this is
maybe as preventative maintenance for you is what
I'm saying, or maybe you might have some real.
Struggles, it's okay. No matter where you are
on the Spectrum. We hope that you will glean something from that and we
want to equip you and Mason and
Larry want to equip you to do marriage. Well,
so let me pray for us as we
as we go and sometimes I
do some premarital counseling and the first thing that I say to
to these couples is marriages the
second most important relationship you have
The first of which is your relationship with Jesus and so
as we just consider marriages in general,
I think it would be wise of
us just to to remind you of the Gospel
remind you that if it weren't for
Jesus paying the death for your sin, we would
not have that freedom that
Liberation from our sin. And so I
want to read First Corinthians 15 for us.
It is the gospel message. It says
this Paul's writing says I remind you brothers that the
gospel I preach to you which you received and which you stand
and by which you're being saved. If you hold fast to
the word I preach to you unless you believe in vain for I've
delivered to you that of a first importance what
I receive that Christ died for your sins
according to the scripture then he appeared to
see us in the 12 then he appeared to more than 500 brothers
and he raised on the third day according to
scriptures. So that is the gospel that Christ died for your sin.
So that you could be reunited with him and that's the second or
that's the first.
Most important relationship you can have and then the
second is your marriage which we'll talk about this weekend. We pray with
me.
Lord as we open up your word and we as we
listen to to Larry speak to us tonight God I
pray for marriages in this room. I pray
that you strengthen that you equipped that you Empower
husbands and you and support and
comfort wives.
And all across the board.
Just to do marriage well to be a representation
of your love for your
breath.
We love you father. It's in your name. We pray amen.
Let's welcome Larry Roberts, my friend.
Okay.
Can you hear me? Okay. All right, good. I can hear myself.
All right. Well good evening and welcome.
I'm just gonna tell you one. I hope I don't fall off the stage.
I'm not there. I'm not a I'm not a speaker.
I'm not a teacher. I'm a therapist. It's my that's my full-time
job. And so this kind of thing here is terrifying and
this is like there's a lot of people here.
Like I thought 12 jurors was
scary.
Holy cow to be standing up here thinking that.
All these people are judging you, right? That's that's just kind of
scary for me.
So bear with me we'll get through this and we'll get
to go home in a little bit.
All right. I really am glad you're here. I'm truly truly
honored that you're here. And I'm
excited to be here. I do love talking about marriage and
trying to help couples have the
marriage that they want. But first I just
want to share with you my family. They
are my my
inspiration. They're my life and I
love them so much. So the first
one in the middle, obviously, that's my wife Candice. We
met at OBU and August of
1989 met the night before classes started there.
And she was a freshman. She was just going to date and
she was gonna have a good time. She was a Minister's kid and lo and
behold she met this guy from
Ardmore and she didn't have
a chance after that.
So she she had one. She's made
one terrible decision in 31 years, and she's still
paying for it.
Right now so so that's her our family
is a little complicated, but he didn't
start out that way.
It really didn't start out that way at all. It started out Simply enough
with Ashley Ashley's up in the upper left-hand Corner up there our little
our little girl. She was our first one we had in college. Well, she
grew up met Quinn at OBU. They moved to Colorado.
They got married. That's him there in the bottom left and and
they live in Colorado because you
can snowboard there and they're never coming home. So
they're never coming home to Oklahoma.
They'll come to visit but they're not coming home to stay.
Later on, we had Nathan in the
upper, right? He was our
second kid and then we were finished after that. We didn't want
to have any that right because it's easy to go to a restaurant and sit with
four people and if you go to like six flags and
everybody can ride I grew up in a family of five. And
so somebody always set out. I don't want to do that. So we after after
the two kids we were like we're done we're done. And so
Nathan we had him we were finished. He grew
up married his middle school sweetheart Taylor. They've been
married about four years now, but been together like oh like
11 12 years like that's crazy.
So our life was great up until I
was easy not complicated right? We're it
was just very simple.
Then when Ashley was in the eighth grade and Nathan was in the fifth grade
we brought on two more
kids.
Miranda and Veronica. They're at the top Miranda's on
the left and Veronica's on the right. And yes, you see four. You're not seeing double
a few a few
months after that.
After we took them we learned that they had a full blood
baby sister.
There was just a couple months old and so we brought
her on in August of '07
on their second birthday. So
Well now we have.
Five kids just like that. We have five kids. It was
like Walmart in our little house. It was like everybody bumping into one another.
We just putting people wherever we could fit them, but it
was okay.
So then life goes on we kind of go through our lives and navigate our
kind of fun but complicated life as best we can raising the
girls.
And then a few years in we learned. Oh, they
have another full blood baby sister that we didn't
we didn't know about we got to meet her once and then she
kind of went away for a few years.
Well, long story short two years ago a little
over two years ago. We learned that she
was not in a good place.
And so we we went got her
and we got guardianship of her and we've
had her now for a little
over two years. And so that's her on the bottom right that she's Trisha. She's
13. So my twins are 17 Leah is 15 and
Tricia is 13.
So there's boxes at the back. You can drop your donations
in we helpful. You can venmo cash
app. Whatever you got. You can just make Candice's right here drop her
some money. We need all help we can we can get. Okay.
So here's a little bit about me. I don't
like that when I turn around see the back of my head. I don't like that. Here's
a little bit about me. I graduated from OBU
the second time in 2003. I
don't know why I decided to go back to school. I barely got
through the first time.
I don't know why they took me back. I don't have any idea but I
went back got a master's degree in marriage and family therapy in 2003 2005.
I got my license 2006. I
started a private practice by myself because I really just
wanted to work on my own.
2008 I moved in with a partner and
he and I started just working together. And then
in 2013, we grabbed another partner and we started the
center for Christian Counseling in care there in Shawnee.
And as of today, there's eight of us there. There's seven
full-time therapists and and then we have an
intern or a she's a licensed
candidate. So we have we have
eight total.
In 2014. I was invited to come and
teach at OBU in the marriage
of family therapy department. I thought oh, this is great. I can go back and do that.
And so I started that and I did that for eight
semesters eight fall semesters. And so
I'm not teaching this year. I stepped away from that because I really just
wanted to focus on couples.
I really just wanted to work with them and kind
of really narrow my Lane of work down to just working
with couples and and kind of moving this other stuff away.
It was fun. I really enjoyed that. It's where I'm at
Mason that's where I've met a lot of therapists and
They have that was really enriching for me. I enjoyed that
part, but I just needed to move on and focus on
what I wanted to do.
During the during the pandemic though.
We we kind of learned and maybe
some of you learned that work was a
big buffer for couples.
Right, they really didn't know how
emotionally disconnected they
were until they were home all the time.
and their kids were with them all the time and it
Kind of became like metal on metal for them and they started
showing up in my office
and calling and just in droves they
started showing up and so it's it was at that
point. I was like, I really narrowed my focus just to work on couples because
there's a lot of great individual therapists out
there. But what I was learning was that there was not a lot
of good marital therapy.
And so and I think I I'm a good marital therapist.
And so it's like I just want to focus on that and give more people
the opportunity to do that. So so that's
a little bit about
About me so let's get started. First
thing I want to say is I don't know if anybody staff here whatever
but I see a lot of people doing this it might be a little
warm and so I don't know if there's an air conditioner in the building or
what maybe the
Bill's not pay, I don't know.
Tithe people whatever you can
do to help out. Like I
said, I'm incredibly honored that you're here.
And and I pray that you're
here to take your marriage to a place that you never thought
possible.
And listen, it may sound like a
preacher story may sound like something out of a Preacher story
or maybe even make me sound like a snake oil salesman. If any of your
old enough to remember what that was, but the
reality is it's possible. It is possible in
the time that we have this this weekend tonight and
tomorrow put your marriage on the right
track. So I hope you're going to be willing to
take even a small risk.
Right in kind of
being vulnerable and being able to just to engage with your spouse. I'm
not going to ask you to engage with other people around you. I'm not going
to do that. But just with your spouse, I'm going to
ask that you take some of these small risks just to be able to
be as more open as or as open
as you possibly can and maybe help bring you guys a little bit closer
together.
Okay. So the first session tonight, I
want us to consider this one main question and that
is why did we get married?
Why do we get married though? I don't know for sure. My guess
is
Most of you in here are married.
I mean as I'm kind of looking around the room I see
there's a lot of couples maybe some
of you are preparing for marriage. That's that's a good
place to be as well. So what I what I
do know for sure is that I'm not a researcher.
I don't know actually how many people get
married and I really don't know what to believe about
divorce statistics.
Right. I just don't what I do
know is that when people is
that a lot of people still get married?
The majority of people on the planet still get married. They
want to be with somebody right? And so
they all get married with the hope that they're gonna
stay together for a lifetime, right? I mean imagine going to that wedding that
they don't they're not planting on being together for
a lifetime.
Kind of scary to be at that wedding, I think.
so
let me just say this as I do know, they
get married many people get married.
And they want to stay that way but some things happen along
the way.
And it kind of make a second guess our decisions.
I know Candice and I early on in our marriage we've had that you've probably
had that maybe you've never had that and that's
okay, too.
But this is when problems begin to arise early
on.
Right spouses began. We kind of look at each other differently, right
then we once did.
I'm going to discuss this more in
our second session tonight. We talk about what happened to us.
And and then tomorrow we will kind of talk about
how to get out of this.
When we with with
as we answer the question, how do we reconnect? How do
we reconnect with each other?
So that's a simple enough plan. And so what I do want to say is that listen
I
I don't expect that everybody in here is in
trouble.
I know some of you and I don't expect that you're in trouble. I expect
maybe this is just a date night for you.
And you just want to go and spend some time doing this together Candice
and I we're gonna go to marriage conference at
our church Emmanuel Baptist Church in Shawnee. We're going
to go that next weekend.
We're not in trouble.
At least I know I might be in trouble. I don't
know but but we
want to go just because it's a good thing to do to spend
some time together and learn something and you may learn something. You
may learn nothing. If in reality
you just come here and you spend the weekend with your spouse and you have a great time
and you reconnect on something something touches you
man. That's great. That's a win so
They're probably are some people in here who's struggling.
And who are not sure and who are reaching out and this can
help you too. Okay?
So tonight I want to I want to tell you I want to start by telling
you just one.
Simple truth. I do like to keep things simple.
One simple truth and that is there is one enemy.
in your life
and it is not the person sitting beside you.
Right, it's not him. It's not her.
It's the enemy is the the
devil right Satan.
It is this force in this world that
seeks to destroy all the good blessings that
God has given us and its first
Target.
Is your marriage?
We're going to talk about that from the moment Adam and
Eve were in the garden together.
The enemy sought to separate them from God and
then to separate them from one another.
He did it then.
He's doing it today.
and my prayer for you and my life's work is
that
We help that. I help couples recognize this
terribly destructive cycle and how
to stop it from destroying this.
Good blessing.
That God has given us.
Okay.
So every couple gets married kind of
with the belief that their marriage will last until
death do they part? But but as we all know and and maybe
some of you have experience, it doesn't always work
out that way.
Right in the in the dance of marriage. Sometimes we
step on each other's toes, right? You probably had your
toes stepped on before and it hurts, right? It's not always very
fun when that happens.
It's then that our culture comes along and it
says well, you must not
been compatible with that person.
Or he was a narcissist.
Or there's somebody better out there for you.
right, that's
It's at that point. We kind of developed a belief. Well, maybe
marriage isn't for everybody. Maybe it wasn't for me.
And and then kind of life kind of falls apart for us.
It's too difficult at times and so and
then it kind of leads to misery.
But the reality is especially as Believers, we
know nothing could be further from the truth. It wasn't
designed to be that way.
We all know mayor just tough. Right we've experienced that and I knew during
tough times people. I want to get out of it. That makes sense
that sometimes they want to find something better or someone better.
But also know that people will do anything they can.
to save their marriage
But why?
Why do they want to save something? That is the source of
such misery? Why do they want to save something? That's
Challenging or difficult or tough at
times. Why would they want to why do they want to do that?
Why why go to all the trouble?
Why go to I mean, why do they go by these marriage
books marriage help books? Why do they go to counseling? Why
do they go to conferences or seminars workshops where everyone
calls us? Why do they do those things?
right
It's for the same reason that we go to our kids ball games.
Is for the same reason that we go to cheer competitions?
To my girls are cheerleaders. They're cheering right now. Right we go
to cheer competitions. They do those things we go to dance what
we don't go to dance recitals that are not at night think the Lord that's expensive.
You're probably a part of that but you do those
things why or even go to you don't even go to these activities
with your spouse that you don't particularly enjoy for 30 years.
I played competitive Racquetball and I would go into these
tournaments and in play and Candice went to some of
them not to all of them because she didn't enjoy it.
But us does so she went I went
to a ballet or something with her one time. I don't
enjoy that but us does so we go right
marriage conferences. Maybe you don't enjoy that but us does so
you go.
right
we go because we love our kids we go because we
love each other and we want to show them by supporting
them, right? This is this is why
spouses fight so hard to keep
their marriages alive because they simply love each
other. That's why I don't know that's good.
And they want what their marriage was supposed to be?
They want what their marriage was designed to be
and we all know what that was It was supposed to be incredible right
if we go back and we're gonna go back and look at the Garden here
in a minute as we go back and look at that. It was supposed to be incredible.
It was supposed to be loving.
It was designed to be warm and peaceful and intimate it
was designed for us to be spiritually and emotionally
and physically connected to each other.
for a lifetime
That's the way it was designed.
But many couples I see.
Come to me because they have lost this
connection.
And they are lonely in a house with someone
they love and they don't have any idea why.
Since we were designed to be in a relationship.
The opposite of that is that we were not designed to be
alone.
I know this is true in my own life. Candice is with
me. I don't like it, you know.
I'm a golfer. I go play I go like golf trips
with my buddies and those are fun.
But I miss her she goes on her trips
with her with her girlfriends and I like that
she does that.
But it's lonely. I miss her.
We weren't designed to be alone and God even said in his
word.
That it was that it was not good for man
to be alone.
So listen to Genesis to 18 to 28.
If you want to turn in your put it
on your phones, you can you can pull it up, but you can just listen just these 10
verses.
Then the Lord God said it's not good that man
should be alone. See I told you that's what he said.
I will make him a helper fit for him.
Now out of the ground the Lord had formed every beast of
the field and every bird of the heavens and he brought them to the man to see
what he would call them and whatever the man called every living
creature. That was its name. So let me stop first
again.
It's not good for man to be alone.
So God said he would make a Helper, but then God makes Adam
name all the animals.
That doesn't seem to make much sense.
I need to make a helper fit for him, but he doesn't make a helper fit
for him. It makes him a go name all the animals.
That makes sense. Okay, maybe just think let me
read on.
The man gave names to all the livestock into the birds of the heavens into
the every beast of the field, but for Adam there was not
found a helper for him.
a helper fit for him
So God made all the animals.
There was not one that looked like Adam.
What was he doing?
What was God doing with this?
Little bit just to be honest. It seems like a little bit of a cruel joke.
right
reading on so the Lord God caused the Deep Sleep to follow
man to fall upon the man and while he slept he took
one of his ribs and he close up his place with flesh and the rib that
the Lord God had taken from the man he made into a woman and he
brought her to the man.
the man said hot dog
What husband wouldn't want to wake up next to his naked wife, right? I'm
kind of
okay, maybe you don't I don't know then the man
said this at last.
This at last is bone in my bone. And if you read it in
the Hebrew, that's exactly what he's saying hot dog.
I have somebody that looks like me.
I have somebody for me.
He says this at last his bone of my bone and Flesh
of My Flesh. She shall be called woman because she
was taken out of man. Therefore man. Shall
leave his father and his mother and hold fast to
his wife and they shall become one flesh and
the last but definitely not the least important verse
In this passage his verse 28 and the man and his
wife were both naked and they were not ashamed.
There was nothing between them.
Right, they didn't have fig leaves yet.
There was nothing but openness and transparency.
and intimacy
the only piece of the garden experience that
was not good.
The only piece of in the creation story that
was not good was that man
was alone.
Let that sink in.
That's really really important.
As a therapist who deals in the world of emotions
more than most people.
I feel sad for Adam.
And if you really kind of think about that, I feel sad for out and my first
thought goes to how does he feel?
And so if we were to ask him Adam, how did it
feel if he could tell us he's going to give us a typical man response fine.
Right. That's what he's going to say. I think he was fine in the beginning, right? He
had a purpose.
Namely animals he had some Authority.
And he got to use some creativity.
And there's probably all kinds of stories about why did he do that and a woman
wasn't there and you know in the man and he didn't want her there
or he would be doing it wrong. I just probably all kinds of jokes about that. But the
reality is he was there he had some purpose he
had some Authority he got to use some creativity and I'm
sure for a while it was great and I'm sure he would have said yeah, I was great.
But the more animals he named.
The more animals he named the more. I think he began
to realize to really important truths.
You ever thought about this?
There was two.
Of every one of them.
And not a single one of them looked like
him.
I always make the joke about that. Well that hairy back gorilla,
but she had somebody.
Right. There was nobody for him.
Which really begs the question.
Why would God make Adam feel loneliness?
Without having anyone to help him.
Why would God make him feel that loneliness without
anybody to support him?
Well, I think for two reasons.
I think this was for Adam to learn
to rely on God to supply all of his needs.
right
I think that's fair and the second one I think was
for Adam to experience life without human
interaction.
So that he could feel the loneliness.
To me the the emotional ramifications of
this are far-reaching and I think the
impact is profound.
Many people tend to focus on the solely
on the first point.
And they kind of minimize the second point the first point that was Adam was to
rely on God's solely it meaning they ignore their
internal design for relationship.
And say we should only rely on God for for everything.
I'm not going to argue with that.
I think that's true and I don't think that can be denied
at all.
However, it can't be the only point of the text.
because if it was
If it was Adam God wouldn't have
he would have left that part out.
He would apart he would left out the part about needing a helper.
He designed them.
Yeah, so sorry.
He would have left out the part about being needing a
helper for Adam.
So we have to be mindful of both of these points because I
think they're both true.
And find in these find in both
of these and in the creation of Eve.
the heart of our loving father
So let's agree. It's all agree that God
created that God created
Adam and he wants him to rely first and foremost wants all
of us to rely first and foremost on him to provide
all that we need right? It's a
Sole Provider for all that we need but also let's also
agree that he wanted Adam and Eve.
To have each other and that he designed them to need
each other as well. And if you think about this this is
I think is really important even needed Adam for protection.
And Adam needed Eve for support and
this is exactly where the enemy attacked
them.
So notice from the text that God didn't create the
only the male animals.
First and leave them to notice their loneliness.
Before he created them.
He created both of them at the same time and both
from the dirt.
But not Eve.
He didn't create Eve from the dirt.
I believe God would want I believe God wanted her today.
I believe God wanted her then. I believe God wanted her to
have a special place and Adam's life.
That's where I want to focus tonight and tomorrow.
The place that we have in each other's lives.
Throughout our time together.
Tonight and tomorrow I'm gonna ask you to
talk to each other.
And kind of share any of the feelings that come up for you and he thoughts
that come up for you at certain points along the way these things
can be they're really boring. If you're just listening to
me or listening it just any one person.
So and I know it can be uncomfortable. It is
for me at times and undoubtedly,
there's some of you have not talked about much else than the weather or
work or kids and in you know,
quite a while.
But but please take this opportunity to just engage
with one another.
And give you your marriage an opportunity to
become what it was designed to be.
So this first exercise that I'm going
to ask you to do is I just want
to talk to each other for a minute a couple minutes about these
two questions. I think we have them on the screen. Yeah.
What do you think about God creating Eve from Adam and not
from the dirt? And how do you feel about God creating Adam and
letting him be alone for a while?
So if you would just turn to each other if you
want to spread out a little bit you can do that too, but just kind of just talk about
that for a minute while I get a drink
and just kind of talk about that.
for a few minutes
Okay.
So listen, I realize that exercise is like this kind of
sharing with each other at times can
be a little awkward.
I mean, I know it is for me at times, you know to be able to do that.
When I'm working with couples and I have them.
turn to one another and share with one another it they
often their kind of fear response
shows up and
they start laughing. They don't want to look at each other.
They you know, it's it's just
it can be awkward at times.
what I look for and what I'm hoping you guys are
going to
take from it is an experience of being able to just turn
each other and talk to each other.
It's quite often that people as couples.
We just don't do that.
And so I appreciate you doing that and we're going to be doing that some more.
tonight and tomorrow
So how does Genesis 2?
18 to 28
connect to the this main question. Why did we
get married?
I think it speaks very loudly and very
clearly to us.
About the nature of our divinely inspired internal
design.
To be deeply connected to one person for a lifetime. You
guys have heard this about a one
flesh relationship.
Right. It's more than just physical spiritual. It's
emotional.
It's physical. It's all of that.
That's the way we were designed.
And I think it's the main reason the the overwhelming majority
of people still get married.
Even despite what they hear about marriage.
Or what they what they know about marriage themselves.
Dr. Sue Johnson she is a researcher. She's
a marital therapist. She's a founder of emotionally focused couples therapy.
She's in Canada. She says this
it's up on the screen.
Love is the continual search for a basic secure
bond with someone else.
Through this Bond spouses in love become emotionally
dependent on each other for nurturing soothing.
and protection
I think this statement perfectly correlates
with the passage in Genesis.
And it basically confirms that we have this divinely inspired
need for emotional connection.
from our spouses
So some of you have undoubtedly heard of
attachment Theory right heard of
attachment Theory but attachment theory. Yes,
it's an evolutionary theory, but
we know that that just means those theorists haven't
realized the or acknowledged
or admitted God's design in
all of this. Right. So if you ever hear Evolution just think
God's design. That's what as far as attachment Theory
goes
Attachment Theory basically says that our need for
this kind of connection this emotional powerful emotional
connection we have is a survival response.
Right. It's a it's the driving force of
the bond of security a child
seeks with its mother.
And this right the drive doesn't go away
when when we become adults.
Have you ever been in your mom's? I know you have.
You've been in a bathroom right your kid, right? You've been
in the bathroom and the kid walks past dad and
finds you and knocks on the bathroom door, right Mom
Mom right trying
to get to you or knocks on the bedroom door night Mom, Dad,
whatever right? I can't get to you.
in those moments
how many of your kids go? Okay. Well, she's
probably busy. I'll just probably go back out here and wait.
For a few minutes and she'll come out and get
me or they'll come out when they're finished right doing taxes
or whatever. They're doing. They'll come out and
No, they don't do that. Right they
Start banging and they start doing everything they can right and
what would happen if you didn't?
Come to them.
They start panicking.
Right. That's the survival response coming
up.
Over a period of time if you never come to them it changes, right
but this is what happens. This is what happens to
us. This is the survival response. This is why couples fight
It's our means of getting us.
It's a means of getting our spouse to see us.
To draw close to us to come to us to show
up for us. It's our cry.
It's our cry so to speak but it's just
an adult version of our cry.
So I want to show you a video that demonstrates.
Exactly what I'm talking about and some of you have probably
seen this before.
But it's it's called a still face video.
This was done. I think back in the maybe in the 90s. They've
read it's been done a couple of times
throughout the years, but this is it's just really interesting. So
I want you to watch this.
Babies this young are extremely responsive
to the emotions
and the reactivity and the social interaction
that they get from the world around
them. This is something that we started studying.
30 40 years ago when people didn't think
that infants could engage in
social interaction in this
still face experiment with the mother did was she sits
down and she's playing with her baby who's about a year
of age.
To the baby the baby gives a greeting back to her
this baby starts pointing at
different places in the world and the mothers trying to engage
her and play with her. They're working to coordinate their
emotions and their intentions
what they want to do in the world and that's
really what the baby is used to and then
we ask the mother.
To not respond to the baby.
The baby very quickly picks up on
this and then she uses all of her abilities to
try and get the mother back.
She smiles at the mother.
She points because she's used to the mother
looking where she points.
The baby puts both hands up in front
of her and says What's Happening Here?
She makes that.
Screechy sound at the mother like come
on. Why aren't we doing this?
Even in this two minutes when they don't
get the normal reaction.
They react with negative emotions, they turn
away. They feel the stress of it. They actually
may lose control of their posture because of
the stress that
there
And what are you doing?
Oh, yes. Oh, would it be girl?
It's a little like The Good the Bad and the
Ugly the good.
Is that normal stuff that goes
on that we all do with our kids?
The bed is when something bad
happens, but the infant can overcome it
after all when you stop the still face the
mother and the baby start to play again.
The ugly is when you don't
give the child any chance to get back to the
good there's no reparation and
they're stuck in that really ugly
situation.
So anybody ever seen that before?
Isn't that interesting?
This is our design.
They were connected and then the baby instantly knew.
Something was wrong. Did you see that baby's face when Mom
turned around? I mean it's heartbreaking. It was like
Just the eyes cut and everything. It was
like it knew wait a minute Something's Happened.
in an instant
That baby knew something was wrong.
Something was happening. We do that too.
As adults we do that too.
Right, we're designed to have that kind of
emotional dependence.
on each other
so we got designed it. It's why God wanted Adam to be alone
in the garden for a little bit so he can figure this out. He needed
to drive this point home. We were designed to
be attached.
not separated
when this happens to us.
When we're not, you know, when our spouse isn't there
for us emotionally we cry.
Just doesn't look like this Baby's cry.
Our cry doesn't our cry to
to reconnect doesn't typically come
from a vulnerable place like this Baby's did right when
we bake when our babies cry we oh we
go and pick them up that right that's reason that they said at the
end of that Mom's the baby's crying and so Mom.
swoop Center to reconnect
cry to reconnect doesn't come from same place.
Comes from this. I mean it comes from this place
of I need you.
And without you I'm terrified.
So instead of our spouse coming to comfort us.
They kind of back off and defend themselves.
And so this is what I'm going to talk about later.
And in the second session tonight.
Now I get that it might be difficult, especially in our culture.
It might be difficult to kind of see dependence as
something that's good as a good quality to have.
Right minions have been many of us
have been taught over the years that dependence is bad.
The dependencies is an in
for males, especially that it's a form of weakness.
But if that's true then our dependence on God would be
bad.
And that's just not the way it is.
Being dependent on him being dependent on
God gives us our greatest sense of security.
Right. We all know that is Believers gives us the greatest
sense of safety.
And since it's his design doesn't it make sense
that he would make us the same way to need our spouse
to be dependent on them emotionally and those
same ways.
To depend on each other for the emotional connection just as
our children depend on us for that to
depend on your spouse to respond to you when
you need them.
To depend on or to you
know to know that you matter to her.
To know that he values you to know that she will be
there for you.
To know that he'll respond to your emotional needs.
the most basic belief of attachment theory
is that
Isolation loneliness us being
alone.
Is both physical and emotional
is traumatizing for us as human beings.
Do you remember?
Do you remember what the Lord told Gideon in judges
6 15 and 16?
After Gideon asked him, how can I save Israel?
My clan is the weakest in Manassas, and
I'm the least of my father's household.
And the Lord said to him.
But I will be with you and you
shall strike down the midianites as one man.
right
Well, you're a New Testament Church. Let me give you a maybe you don't know the
Old Testament. Let me maybe go to the New Testament think about
the word Emmanuel.
Right. We all know what that means coming up on Christmas. We sing
about that. What does that mean? God With Us
right. We we know that
and remember what Jesus told the disciples in Matthew 28 19
and 20.
Right toward the end. He says go and make disciples of all Nations
baptizing them the name of the Father and Son the Holy Ghost teaching all
that. I commit I obeyed teaching them
to obey everything that I have commanded. And then what does he say at
the end?
And remember I will always be with you.
If Jesus would have said and remember.
see boys in heaven
right
Christianity would have probably died out by the weekend.
Right his presence with them
just as his presence with us.
Gives us courage his presence gave them courage to
go and to tell and to endure persecution
and even die for him,
right?
That's what his presence. Does Candace being here
with me tonight.
Gives me courage even if you guys decide halfway
through this thing. You're gonna run me out on a rail.
She's gonna comfort me all the way home.
She's with me.
She'll have me right.
Don't you see then how much sense it makes?
To marry someone to be with us. Yes. We
love them but man we want them with us.
Is why we get married.
Through our Good Times through our bad times through the
through the joys through the Sorrows of life.
Someone with whom we can share our lives together.
That's why we get married.
And so
for us to be alone is scary.
It's also why we will do anything.
We can to reach for the safety of our
spouses.
the anything
is what I'm going to talk about in our
next session
tonight. Okay. We'll talk about that. All right.
That's all I have for now for this piece. I think there's a oh Mason's
gonna come up and kind of tell us what we do now.
We think Larry is really good. I was like
So captivated I've known Larry a long time a
lot of this. I haven't heard so I'm like, I'm really in Courtney and
I are like doing every exercise.
This is great.
So before we go to break Jimmy, do
you want to tell our friends what we've got for them? So
our goal one of the things that as we
began praying about this is if there's
really not much of a follow-up from this and it's
just like a night and a morning. We've
kind of failed you guys. So we asked some
of our community friends to
come out and so we got a couple booths out
there and we really want to help with
the follow-up. And so if you have questions, there'll be
partners out there to talk to about kind of
what's next or things that you may have on
your mind. Yeah. I'll tell you quickly who's out there
and I spent earlier part
of the or later part of the winter going and
meeting some of these folks and inviting them here and those
are legit counselors out there
who may even be ready to set up an appointment with you.
You need to get their card if you're thinking about going and talking
to somebody they're out there and they love
Jesus.
You we made sure that the people we invited are people
who trust God like we do also ministries
of Jesus is out there. We're the neighbors write down
the hill right out these doors that way actually down those
doors. Yeah, so I'm gonna be out at that Booth. I'd love
to talk to you during this break and I just want to remind you
that we've got that QR code if you want to scan that if you haven't submitted your
question, we also have next to these
little tables where we've got the QR code. We've got
index cards and pins if this isn't
working for you and jot it down and
at the MOJ Booth the ministries of Jesus
Booth, we've got a little metal basket you
can drop those in there. Okay, so we're gonna
have a little bit of a break and we'll see
you back here at the end of the countdown, okay.
There's snacks. Oh, there's back there. So help yourself to a
tasty snack pistachios.